in part one of the series we learned
about how the city of Chicago got to be
so segregated in part two we'll look at
what segregation does to a city and in
particular to one of its most vulnerable
populations its students the chicago
public school system is horrible say
least I've gone through 13 years of
schooling and I had never read a book
when I went off to college however
prepared at all our communities that
need the resources the most to get
students to college are the ones that
lack it driving through the streets of
Chicago my hometown it's not hard to see
the difference from one neighborhood to
the next take Halsted Street the
backbone of Chicago you can start on
Halsted in Lincoln Park on the north
side where rows of beautiful townhouses
line the street but travel south ten
miles until you reach 63rd Street just
around the corner from Harold's chicken
and suddenly you're in a very different
part of town nor is the difference more
startling than in Chicago's public
schools so this right here used to be an
elementary school this is one of the 50
schools that Rahm shut down the
community suffers we have the the
property value suffers you got boarded
up houses vacant lots I mean
this community is filled with no hope
there's something about life in a
segregated City that produces
generations of children who don't get
anywhere near the potential to realize
the potential they had when they were
born
Troy was removed from his position as a
school principal last year after
criticizing Mayor Rahm Emmanuel's
mismanagement of the school system in
Chicago most students are black and
Latino and only nine percent are white
about 86 percent of all of its students
are low-income they came to us from
unstable housing conditions they came to
us homeless they came to us hungry they
came to us with the trauma that comes
from being in a neighborhood where
violence is sometimes a regular
occurrence
this trauma that so many of the students
have didn't appear out of nowhere
it came from decades of segregation
policies that have kept people of color
separate in low-income neighborhoods
without access to basic resources like
quality health care and Economic
Opportunity
what was it about my life and
Bronzeville
what was it about my life and back in
the yards what was it about my life in
all-black Englewood that led me to have
such a low assessment of myself Chicago
Public Schools or CPS has been strapped
for cash for years and long argued that
despite having 20% of the students in
the state of Illinois it only receives
fifteen percent of the state's education
funding at my elementary school the
walls were deathly pilling the books
were breaking apart we rarely got new
books like new reading books for the
students unless someone donated them
when I moved here I thought
what in the hell is this why don't we
have this why don't we have that and I
would get stuff like we used to have
that we used to have this and I think
there was just no real broad plan around
like how do you support small high needs
high schools tilden lost nearly $200,000
last year because of enrollment declines
and budget cuts and after a school
improvement grants expired Sweeney had
to layoff his clinical staff who were
helping his most troubled students once
we lost those people we felt it you feel
it when I can't say so what's going on
okay let me go and connect you with miss
so-and-so it's like no Marie's you're
the clinician right now let's have a
seat and sit down let's figure this out
in 2015
Mayor Rahm Emanuel announced 200 million
dollars in school budget cuts and 1,300
staff layoffs across the district I was
impressed by principal Sweeney's ability
to persevere in spite of all of these
odds when you look at that the majority
of the kids in the Chicago Public School
System is black starving communities are
minorities then you say hmm how come all
the politicians and everybody with money
send their kids to private schools
because they know that the public school
system is horrible for parents knowing
how to choose a school is really
complicated there are charter schools
selective enrollment schools magnet
schools and then your regular
neighborhood schools I think parents
make the best choice that they can I
think parents want their students to be
successful parents are trying to give
their their children the best
opportunity but this concept of school
choice is criticized as the tremendous
community's as parents choose to send
their kids sometimes hours away to
charter selective enrollment schools for
example there is little confidence left
in the local neighborhood schools and
because funding is directly tied to
enrollment fewer students means less
funding I'm worried because I know for
myself as a first-generation college
student
I know the difference that equality
education has on kids I just need for
her to be at a place that is going to
equip her with the academic and
social/emotional skills that she needs
to be able to be successful despite the
budget cuts since 2010 CPS has spent
hundreds of millions on the construction
of new schools and expensive additions
but mostly to schools that serve white
middle class students and many have
blamed those in power for making
decisions not in the interest of local
students but in order to profit off the
school system in April the former head
of CPS was sentenced to four and a half
years in prison for corruption we live
in a system that will look at the
education of their child and sabotage it
on purpose we'll intentionally not give
that child which will give another child
who happens to be white right both
babies beautiful both babies deserve it
when it was time for g2 to choose a
school for his own son he struggled with
the choice of sending him to a lower
resource neighborhood school my son is
not as beautiful as any other child he's
not as intelligent as brilliant when I
look at him stars go off of my head in
1971 the Supreme Court did attempt to
desegregate US public schools with
busing and for the most part it worked
minority students fared better at
integrated schools and by 1988
integration had reached its peak but for
many reasons the busing efforts stopped
and today public schools across the
nation including in Chicago are almost
as segregated as they were in the 1960s
when you don't invest in young people
you get unemployment
you get crime you get violence and so
you get blighted communities when you
don't invest in the people from those
communities a good education is supposed
to be a chance at upward mobility some
hope for the future but in Chicago's
public schools that's just not happening
people have to look at the inequity in
Chicago the segregation in Chicago at
that doesn't mean who gets to sit next
to who it means access to resources and
opportunity
the segregation in Chicago is the evil
the intentional sabotage of a babies
education is the evil and I ask people
to think what could be more evil than
that with more than 600 schools the
Chicago Public School System is the
fourth largest in the nation so that's
affecting a lot of kids 400,000 actually
in the next video I'll spend a day on
the city's Southside speaking to a guy
who has a different vision for solving
the city's crime problems